spectacle improbable en ile de france
dimanche les élans courtois ont
participé aux vendanges à la ferme du
mousseau nous avons replanté des pieds
ding
il ya 22 ans car il y avait autrefois
plusieurs pieds de vigne plusieurs
vignobles en ile de france et est le
plus grand en france
et puis là c'est pour créer recréer un
événement festif que dago gicquel lui
dit la vigne est entretenu à l'année par
une équipe de vignerons dont fait partie
roland chevalier
alors quelles sont les différentes
étapes avant de pouvoir récolter ont
taillé au mois de février
donc on va tailler la au mois de février
cette ville ensuite dans le reste de
l'année on entretient les pieds on by
non on aère le raisin commencent à
fleurir à être en grappe à ce moment là
on coupe les gourmands parce que les
gourmands dépassait mis largement et ce
à plusieurs fois viennent ensuite les
vendanges qui ont été avancées de 15
jours cette année parmi les vendangeurs
on retrouve des habitués comme mélissa
et ses quatre enfants qui participent
depuis trois ans elle est venue
ça sympa de voir comment faire le jus de
raisin de rencontrer les gens du village
parce qu'on est du village
cette année les vendangeurs ont ramassé
50 kg de raisin blanc et 150 de raisin
noir grâce auquel on produira environ
120 autres débats et le jus de raisin